[Musique]
on s'attache les cheveux et où nos fils
le tablier cet après midi dans ce
restaurant grec de versailles on va
explorer la cuisine américaine en
anglais ok mais c'est pour les enfants
les adultes de faire nos recettes
américaines
ils ont cuisiné
donc c'est un atelier ludique terim
olten s'est vite rendu compte qu'on
saigne et une longue et des jeunes est
bien plus simple autour d'une activité
c'est ainsi que sont nés ces ateliers
let's go qu'english bon car chaque étape
de la recette est un prétexte pour
enrichir son vocabulaire mais pts
peuvent stocker les différentes équipes
se répartissent les tâches et ce monde
créatif dans la préparation de leurs me
fit équilibré on doit la mise et le
mélange combien de fer en fait un
mélange de farine et des chiffres et en
fait on doit le tamiser et le mettre
dans un bol en fait je crois qu'il doit
peser les gens verront donc je crois
qu'il m'en faut centigrades
une fois les préparations incorporer
dans leurs moules c'est parti pour dix
huit minutes de cuisson terry et ses
élèves lisent la recette et font le
point sur les nouveaux mots a pris
chacun à boissy marten pour partager
avec ma famille
ces ateliers ont lieu durant les
vacances scolaires ainsi que les
mercredis et samedis pensez à réserver
les recettes américaines de terry
knowlton ont leur succès